hey friends how's it going welcome to
deep dive this is a weekly podcast where
i have conversations with entrepreneurs
creators and other inspiring people
about how they find fulfillment in work
and in life and how they live healthier
happier more productive lives as well if
you're new here then hello my name is
ali and in these conversations you can
expect to hear a wide range of things
from like entrepreneurship and
psychology to like mindset and like
productivity tips but also we like to
try and focus some of the conversations
around these five pillars of health
wealth love happiness and impact which
are like the five things that i think
lead to a generally good life and i'm
always curious as to how other i don't
know entrepreneurs create as other
people think about those in the context
of their own lives so whether you want
to figure out what to do with your life
or how to achieve your goals properly or
how to get started with that project
that you've always dreamed of doing or
even how to get a um a spouse and think
more
about relationships and stuff like that
hopefully you'll find something in the
podcast here for you and it's just worth
remembering that we're all here to learn
but at the end of the day there are no
real right and wrong answers to all of
these questions especially these
questions about life and so what you're
going to hear in the podcast is just my
perspective and our guest perspective
we're not gurus we're not trying to say
this is the only way to live life so
take everything you hear with a bit of a
pinch of salt because no one has the
right answers and it's just yeah it's
just perspectives that we're sharing all
that's left to say is i hope you find
the podcast uh entertaining insightful
informative at times and i hope you
enjoy listening to it it'll be available
on all major podcast platforms like
spotify itunes and google podcasts links
to that will be down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on when you're watching this
and if you're listening to this rather
than watching it we also have a youtube
channel so you can just go on youtube
and search a deep dive with ali dal or
just deep dive and you will find it come
up so you can see me and the guests in
glorious hd or 4k for whatever that's
worth if you like the podcast it would
be great if you can leave us a review on
the itunes store and the way that we
engage with comments on the podcast is
usually on the youtube channel itself
because podcast listening platforms
don't really have a way to comment on
things um but yeah that's all the
housekeeping for me i hope you enjoy the
deep dive and yeah we'll see you around
bye